[VIDEO GAME BEEPING]
MARK MIRCHANDANI: We're almost
done with our baseline data ML
and AI quest.
In this episode, I'll introduce
you to the Data Studio Qwik
Start over on Qwiklabs
Data Studio lets you create
dynamic, visually compelling
reports and dashboards.
With Data Studio, you
can easily connect
to a variety of data
sources, visualize your data
through attractive, dynamic,
and interactive reports
and dashboards, and share and
collaborate with others, just
like Google Drive.
This lab will take you only
30 minutes to complete,
and you'll learn how
to create a new report,
add a data source to the report,
add a chart to the report,
and style your report
however you want.
Through three simple steps--
connecting to your
data, visualizing
that data to gain insights,
and sharing and collaborating
on reports produced
--Data Studio
helps you tell great data
stories to better support
business decisions.
You're only one lab away
from completing your quest
and getting your badge.
In case you haven't been
following our other videos,
a quest is a series
of related labs
that form a learning
path on Qwiklabs.
Completing this quest
earns you this badge
to recognize your achievement.
Next up on our quest,
Google Genomics quickstart.